lire andré le croît vif bazar kan à
démissionner les otages américains
toujours retenus à l'ambassade
monsieur giscard d'estaing de retour de
chanonat et propos des auvergnats
alimenteront la réflexion personnelle
le climat social se durcit cgt cfdt
tente de mettre au point une action
nationale 1 messieurs bonsoir d'abord la
retraite de chanonat demain le chef de
l'état regagnera paris après avoir
longuement interrogé bon nombre
d'interlocuteurs pendant ces deux jours
en auvergne un dialogue peut être créé
avec toutes les tendances at il dit tout
à l'heure sur fr3 auvergne celui ci peut
déboucher sur des solutions communes
un entretien qui devait avoir lieu la
veille et qui avait été reportée en
raison d'une manifestation de grévistes
de chez ducelier précisément devant les
locaux de fr 3 auvergne à clermont
ferrand en tout cas conclusion de notre
envoyé spécial paul amar pas de
dramatisation de la part de valéry
giscard d'estaing le tout paris
politique par les spéculoos en flammes
le président se tait mais ce séjour de
48 heures dans sa propriété d'auvergne
n'a pas été synonyme de retraite comme
on l'a dit à paris chanonat n'a été ni
le baden baden du général de gaulle ni
le camp david de jimmy carter valéry
giscard d'estaing n'est pas restée
retranchée dans ce château pendant deux
jours il est sorti à plusieurs reprises
et au volant de sa propre voiture
le président de la république est allé à
la rencontre des auvergnats lycéens élus
locaux cadres ouvriers mère de famille
pendant 48 heures le chef de l'état a
écouté ces français de tous bords et de
toutes générations qui lui ont parlé de
leur travail de leur vie quotidienne et
de leur avenir et ils ont parlé sur un
ton qui a impressionné le président ces
français sont inquiets
valéry giscard d'estaing les a compris
il tiendra compte de leurs
préoccupations et tentera de leur
redonner confiance
ce que les français d'auvergne m'ont dit
at-il précisé se retrouvera dans les
indications que je donnerai plus tard
quelles indications
on ne le sait pas on ne sait pas encore
le président de la république n'a pas
voulu en dire plus il était venu à
chanonat pour écouter et méditer avant
de décider
les interprétations de ce voyage
inhabituelle sur le thème précisément
l'opposition entre le pays réel et le
pays légal ont quelque peu agacé le rpr
qu'a tenu à nouveau aujourd'hui par la
voix de claude labbé à s'expliquer et a
rejeté toute responsabilité dans la
lente se monte d'un bien curieux climat
isac l'ema politique dangereux qui est
née à la suite trois affaires la
dernière étant l' affaire boulin et nous
constatons que aujourd'hui on essaie
peut-être de séparer paris sa province
en disant que c'est à faire créer une
agitation à paris mais que la province
reste calme et que ces affaires touchent
surtout la classe politique comme si
nous n'étions pas les élus de la nation
et comme s'il devait y avoir une sorte
de pays réel est illégal tout ceci n'est
pas de très bon augure pour l'avenir et
nous rappelle des temps fâchent alors
dans ces circonstances et nous disons
nous gaulliste que nous faisons appel à
la plus grande solidarité à l'intérieur
de notre mouvement et que tous les
membres gaulliste du rassemblement pour
la république doit indiscutablement
aujourd'hui se sentir solidaire et unie
parce qu'il y va de l'intérêt de la
france et nous disons cela pour touche
qu'ils détiennent des responsabilités à
l'intérieur d'un autre mouvement ou à
l'extérieur
voilà ce qui est important et nous le
disons vraiment parce que la date du 9
novembre qui représente pour nous vous
le savez beaucoup de choses approche et
que c'est le moment où on doit surtout
penser à la france même si nous pensons
aussi beaucoup à la nos compagnons
disparus
j'ajoute que les députés ont voté les
crédits du budget de l'industrie ils
vont maintenant se pencher sur celui de
la défense
j'ajoute aussi puisque nous évoquions
les suite de la mort de robert boulin
que les experts viennent de conclure qu
avant de se noyer le ministre avait
avalé une forte dose de valium
l'entourage du ministre du travail
s'étonne de la date de 2h ou 4h du matin
que l'on a avancé et estime pour sa part
que le décès a eu lieu le lundi à 20h
j'ajoute également que le juge van
ruymbeke qui a été entendu tout à
l'heure par le procureur de la
république et qui avait été mise en
cause par robert
l'un à jurait n'avoir violé en aucune
manière le secret de l'instruction
les affaires sociales maintenant avec
tout d'abord cette rencontre au sommet
entre la cgt et la cfdt elle n'est pas
encore terminée mais apparemment jacques
merino on s'achève on se
on aboutit certainement un centre
d'action commune entre la cgt et la cfdt
oui effectivement à patrick cette
réunion n'est pas encore terminée vous
savez qu'il y à deux points principaux à
l'ordre du jour d'abord faire le bilan
de l'accord du 10 d'actions signé en
sept ans en septembre dernier
et puis surtout décider les
prolongements de cet accord alors la
cfdt a proposé propose en ce moment à la
cgt organisé du 26 au 30 novembre une
semaine d'action interprofessionnelle il
semble que la cgt serait assez disposé à
accepter cette proposition
de son côté la cgt demande à ce que le
14 novembre qui sera la journée de la
dernière réunion entre le patronat et
les syndicats sur le temps de travail
sont organisées à la base dans les
entreprises dans les régions
une mobilisation des travailleurs pour
faire pression sur le patronat
il ne s'agirait pas d'une journée de
grève générale avec grand défilé mais
d'une journée d'actions décentralisées
prenant des formes diverses allant de la
pétition à des arrêts de travail
voilà c'est donc ce point qui est assez
important qui est actuellement en
discussion bien sans attendre ces
rendez-vous un certain nombre de
conflits tourné à l'aigre depuis
quelques jours c'est le cas chez
dassault alstom atlantique et se toucher
les aiguilleurs du ciel ou là on peut
vraiment parler de conflits au point
mort le ciel est resté pratiquement
vides pendant une partie de la journée
dans plusieurs grands aéroports français
et l'action des aiguilleurs du ciel
devrait se prolonger pendant les trois
jours qui viennent et entraîné des
retards ou des annulations pour les vols
prévus de 14h à 17h30 mercredi et
vendredi de 9h à 17h30 judy les
aiguilleurs du ciel qui réclament
l'intégration de toutes leur prime dans
leur salaire sont un peu plus de 2000 en
france mais sans eux
le trafic aérien est paralysé
un autre conflit dur celui d'alstom
belfort dont l'usiné est occupée depuis
40 jours est entré ce soir dans une
phase critique avec la réunion de la
commission de conciliation qui pourrait
soit constaté l'échec de la négociation
cela autoriserait la direction à faire
évacuer l'usiné soit marqué une nouvelle
étape dans la discussion entre la
direction et les syndicats
ceux-ci qui semble-t-il ne veulent pas
de rupture ont préparé des
contre-propositions il n'est pas exclu
que la négociation se poursuivent à
paris
mais un troisième conflit prend de
l'ampleur c'est celui des usines
dassault quinze mille ouvriers en tout
ou depuis cette semaine deux heures de
débrayage ont lieu chaque jour à l'appel
de la cgt et de la cfdt
aujourd'hui plusieurs usines et est
occupé à argenteuil boulogne billancourt
5u biarritz
les grévistes réclament des
augmentations de salaires et la
réduction de la durée du travail
alors pour ceux qui doivent prendre
l'avion sachez que tout cela entraîne
mais sur de grosses perturbations pour
les compagnies aériennes alors pour ce
qui est des compagnies nationales vous
pouvez vous le voyez téléphoné à air
france au 320 15 55 à air inter oc 187
12 12 et à lutter à aux 775 75 75
sachez par ailleurs que 150 militants de
la cgt ont occupé en fin de matinée les
locaux de radio france il voulait du
temps d'antenne en vue des élections
prud'homales la politique étrangère
maintenant avec tout d'abord à teyran la
démission ce matin de mehdi bazargan
démission acceptée aussitôt par
l'ayatollah khomeiny ce qui n'avait pas
été le cas lors des précédents coups de
colère du premier ministre iranien
ceci donc alors que se poursuit
l'occupation par les étudiantes de
l'ambassade américaine à taire
alger jeudi dernier le 30e anniversaire
du déclenchement de l'insurrection
algérienne sur la tribune officielle
deux hommes pour mettre à profit
l'événement pour discuter avec mehdi
bazargan zbignew brzezinski
ils vont parler des rapports entre
l'iran et les états unis mais et c'est
là tout le problème
à aucun moment il n'évoque rond
l'extradition du shah l'extradition de
la rue la réaction de la rue ne tardera
pas les étudiants islamiques prenant
peut-être de cours laissant la commune i
lui-même envahissent l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran
près d'une cinquantaine de personnes en
otages exige l'extradition du shah et
demandent ouvertement la démission de
monsieur bazardant soupçonnait de sang
qui manque aux américains ils l'ont
obtenue aujourd'hui en fin de matinée
c'est la première cause de la démission
de mehdi bazargan la deuxième cause
c'est la désorganisation de la vie
politique en iran
ami de longue date de la haye de
l'arménie mehdi bazargan en avait
accepté dès le début d'être le premier
ministre de la révolution iranienne mais
très vite il allait se heurter à la
multiplicité des pouvoirs religieux a
comme civil à terre en fête
neuf mois après sa prise de fonctions
accusé d'être un agent de l'occident
mehdi bazargan ne décidez pratiquement
plus rien les ordres venaient
directement de l'ayatollah khomeiny où
es tu es pris sous la pression de la rue
dans ces conditions le premier ministre
iranien ne pouvait que remettre une
troisième fois sa démission l'ayatollah
khomeiny qui l'a acceptée celui ci est
aujourd'hui seul pour diriger le pays
mais de la même façon il est désormais
l'unique responsable du bon ou du
mauvais déroulement de la révolution
iranienne une révolution et ses
développements suivi avec intérêt aux
états unis de washington jacques sicard
de confirmer la position du gouvernement
américain
impuissance totale pour l'instant
renforcée par la démission du premier
ministre iranien
les américaines ont plus l'interlocuteur
direct à téhéran et il espère que des
nations amies de lire ans pourront jouer
la conciliation auprès de l'ayatollah
khomeini 60 villes américaines sont en
danger a rappelé lui-même le président
carter y a exclu toute action militaire
en pleine campagne électorale
le gouverneur connolly candidat
républicain en d'exploiter la suite en
contactant le président de faiblesse
fumant léger à cette occasion d'art
l'intransigeance de téhéran pourrait
déboucher sur une crise mondiale
au moindre sunna patience de washington
situation très tendue également bolivie
certaines dépêches font état de 300
morts d'autres ne parle que de 50
toujours est il que le coup d'état
tourne mal mais que le colonel la touche
garde toujours le pouvoir à maintes
reprises nous vous avons parlé du
problème des palestiniens mais par la
force des choses nous nous en tenons à
l'aspect strictement politique de ce
problème très brûlant or derrière les
idées il ya aussi les hommes et les
hommes peuvent nous révéler de bien
curieux aspects de leur personnalité
ainsi ibrahim sousse délégué de lpa
paris va-t-il de m'asseoir s'exprimer à
rennes mais pas avec des mots avec ses
doigts
à
ibrahim sousse on vous connaît comme
représentant de l'olp et en france on
vous a entendu sur ses écrans vous a vu
être le porte parole de l'organisation
palestinienne mais on ne vous
connaissais pas comme pianiste
concertiste et j'avoue que cette double
personnalité déconcerte un petit peu je
ne trouve pas je trouve ça tout à fait
normal c'est une diversification
d'activité l'activité de l'ol paie des
activités militantes
ça c'est une activité personnelle alors
racontez nous tout de même un peu
comment un petit arabe petit arabe de
palestine se met au piano
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui se passe
comment c'est arrivé eh bien il s'est
mis au piano par hasard il y avait un
vieux piano qui traînait dans un foyer
d'accueil aux réfugiés palestiniens et
le melon 2050 dont les palestiniens
quitté quand un conte nous a chassés
plutôt en attaque it et voilà on en a
été chassée et lors de cette période
d'exode il y avait ce vieux piano qui a
été laissée derrière dans ce foyer par
les anglais qui avaient quitté la
palestine en 48
je me suis mis par hasard à pianoter ça
n'a pas empêché aussi que je baigne dans
la musique arabe chez moi à la maison et
partout ailleurs
je pense que deux cultures peuvent très
bien habiter un même individu
vous avez étudié le piano longtemps
professionnellement un pari très
longtemps j'ai fait
j'ai étudié à paris j'ai étudié à
londres je fais aussi une année en
allemagne et j'ai donné mon monde de mon
dernier concert en 1968
car là j'ai été plutôt plutôt déchiré
entre ma carrière et entre mon devoir de
militants
c'est un homme comprend âgées à une
voiture de police qui le suit activement
oui
mon prédécesseur kanak assassiné à paris
le premier représentant de l'olp est
comme ça va être également assassiné à
paris
quand vous donner un concert aux gardes
du corps sont dans la salle toujours je
préfère pas en fait mais à vous dire je
ne sais pas parce qu'ils font leur
travail eux-mêmes sans me consulter
qu'est ce que vous voulez de mort vous
le lp vous voulez vraiment beau exister
avec un état hébreu ou bien vous voulez
en fait ils disparaissent et que vous
retrouviez l'intégralité de la palestine
nous souhaitons la disparition de
personnes deuxièmement si eux acceptent
de vivre en paix avec nous car nous
sommes les victimes
ils sont des agresseurs si eux acceptent
de vivre en paix avec nous nous vivrons
perdre et que nous avons été les
premiers à préconiser une coexistence
sur la terre de la palestine 2 est
dingue mais par contre par contre à
l'heure actuelle
qu'est ce qu'on entend on n'entend
qu'eux qui à la colonisation de tout
l'intérieur de tous les territoires
palestiniens par les israéliens
j'en entend un son de cloche d'un des
terroristes comme monsieur begin qui dit
qu'il veut qu'il veut toute la terre de
la palestine plus des terres arabes qui
sont autour
comment il ya un dialogue possible
vraiment comprends pas ce que vous dites
begin et un terroriste mais les
israéliens disent arafat et à l'intéreur
ici tout le monde continue à traiter de
terroristes comme ça ya un dialogue
croyait vraiment plus que s'établir un
jour ou bien c'est une plaisanterie moi
je pense que avant de demander à la
victime d'établir un dialogue avec son
agresseur
avec 100 après ça il faut demander
peut-être à l'agresseur de de beer qui
d'abord de reconnaître qu'il a fait
victime tout un an tout un peuple qui
l'a chassé de sa terre qui l'a chassé de
ces maisons vous avez quel âge y voit
une source j'ai 36 ans
et vous verrez un jour à votre avis le
certainement certainement oui leurs
représentants israéliens à paris mais
rosen l'ambassadeur d'israël à paris
était ici même notre invité samedi soir
libération du prix du bifteck de l'asu
noix de veau et de l'est chine de porc
elle marquera une nouvelle étape dans la
libération des prix de la viande décidée
par le ministère de l'économie le
nucléaire à la une de l'actualité cette
semaine alors que se poursuit le
chargement du coeur de la centrale de
tricastin vous envoyer en ce moment les
l'image la piscine la piscine centrale
là le dossier sera évoqué demain par le
conseil des ministres plus précisément
sur l'information en matière nucléaire
informations selon le chef de l'état qui
doit être attentive et objective nous
proposons d'ailleurs demain dans notre
journal de 20h à reportage sur la
procédure d'implantation d'une centrale
nucléaire
des juges en grève à l'appel du syndicat
de la magistrature qui compte environ
1000 adhérents
les juges de syndicats ont observé
aujourd'hui une journée de grève pour
protester contre la réforme de
recrutement réforme actuellement en
cours
sortira sortira pas le film de michel
drac le pull-over rouge fait l'objet
d'une demande de saisie le film qui doit
en principe commencer sa carrière demain
relate la sphère ranucci le père de la
petite fille enlevée et assassinée il ya
cinq ans ne veut pas que l'on gagne de
l'argent avec la mort de son enfant et
il n'est pas d'accord avec la version du
scénariste gilles perrault trop
favorable à christian ranucci guillotiné
il y a trois ans le juge rendra sa
décision demain dépôt de bilan aux
éditions bout dies parmi les sept
journaux qui édite cette société deux
seulement ne disparaîtront pas le
journal des librairies et espacés
civilisation parisse métro en revanche
mourra pour la seconde fois presse
toujours une petite révolution à lyon
les habitants de la ville et des
alentours ne reconnaissent plus leur
journal
on leur à transformer l'institution qui
était devenu le progrès on sait le
nouveau pdg depuis six mois jean charles
ligne aile 36 ans anticonformiste
dynamique tout à la fois on le dit de
gauche et la grande bourgeoisie
lyonnaise a tendance à le soupçonner
ses démêlés d'abord avec son cousin g
mains pour obtenir la direction du
journal puis avec le concurrent le
dauphiné libéré n'ont pas adouci
l'atmosphère de le voir dans notre
dossier du marty dossier réalisé par
dominique torrès et bernard puces au
lion dans l'ancienne capitale des soyeux
les grandes affaires se tissent toujours
derrière des murs centenaires atmosphère
feutrée pouvoir en mai les intérêts
confondues chacun connaît les règles du
jeu et chacun y trouve son compte
et soudain il ya six mois le rachat du
journal le progrès par un jeune homme de
36 ans déjà directeur général du groupe
expansion dont il possède 40% des parts
jette le trouble dans le tout lyon vous
savez en fait tout ce qui bouge des
roses mais si dans votre nom de rotherm
dérangé c'est gêné il faut savoir que
n'ai aucunement l'intention de jeûner
qui conte cela étant dit on vit dans un
pays dans une époque où l'ordre établi
et ce qui compte le plus alors qu'est ce
qui peut déranger dans ma personne
l'âge surnom chez 36 ans est peut être
un peu jeune pour certains pour occuper
le poste que j'occupe c'est sûr il ya
aussi le fait que depuis que je suis la
tête du progrès le progrès a un peu
changé et par exemple que la position
que nous avons pris par rapport au
pouvoir quel qu'il soit n'est plus la
même que celle qui était avant c'est à
dire que en fait le progrès n'est plus
l'objet de personnes on ne sera plus
l'objet de personnes alors si dérangé
c'est dire ce qu'on pense de faire ce
qu'on dit alors sûrement je dérange
lorsque la guerre ouverte avec un
bourgeoisie lyonnaise et surtout avec la
mairie monsieur rend presque détester
monsieur li nian contre le terme paraît
d'une violence extrême
je vais d'abord aucun motif de tester un
homme qui a quitté lyon il ya un certain
nombre d'années qui vient d'y revenir il
ya six mois
et puis ensuite dans la mesure où
monsieur ville elle se comporte à notre
égard en adversaire nous avons à le
combattre à lui répond nous on sera
établie ultime défense à le détester
certainement pas il n'est pas de
publications du progrès ou sur un plan
quelconque notre municipalité ne soit
accrochée
nous sommes par exemple critiqué les
accueillons voulons
et ça prend un tour tellement
systématique maintenant que nous
pourrons pas ne pas discerner une
agression dirigée contre certains vous
reprochent à les produits trop loin ce
qui est vrai c'est que quand je dis je
veux faire lorsqu'on post ça devient il
veut sortir des scandales et quand je
donne comme instruction de ne plus avoir
dans le journal d'informations dites de
complaisance et que la conséquence de
cette instruction
c'est qu'on voit moins la tête des
notables lyonnais dans le journal on en
déduit que je veux être maire de lyon or
je ne suis pas candidat à la mairie de
lyon pour deux raisons la première si je
n'ai qu'un objectif de faire ou de
refaire du progrès un grand journal et
la deuxième c'est que je ne veux que le
progrès ou mohamed ne soit pomme de
discorde entre les lyonnais mais au
contraire instrument de cohésion entre
derrière ces attaques se pose de
problème mais spectaculaire achat du
progrès après des années de luttes
balzacienne entre jean charles inial et
son cousin jean vraiment jean-charles
ligne elle gagne par un majestueux coup
de poker en rachetant d'abord 50% des
parts du journal à sa mère puis il ya
six mois et 50 % restants à 70 ce qui
était jusqu'à présent une guerre froide
entre cousins germains devient une lutte
entre deux empires de presse dont les
intérêts sont étroitement liés les
accords établis en 1966 mettant en
commun tous les moyens techniques et
commerciaux sont aujourd'hui en suspens
hier dépenses et recettes étaient
partagés aujourd'hui on parle de divorce
le dauphiné libéré a demandé un tribunal
arbitral de constater la rupture des
accords du sel du programme le 19
octobre
contraint et forcé par l'attitude de son
confrère le progrès a demandé aux
arbitres de constater la rupture aux
torts du dauphiné libéré
il apparaît dans ces conditions
clairement pour moi sur un point des
deux parties sont d'accord la rupture la
rupture devient un fait
j'ajouterai que la position du progrès
n'étant pas tactique la rupture est
irréversible me louis chevaux pdg du
dauphiné libéré est convaincu que les
jours du jeune seigneur sans compter
avez vous l'impression que mes ces
lignes elle va pouvoir s'en tirer sans
méchanceté je ne le crois pas il a
acheté très très cher le journal les
l'argent lui la beauté dans les banques
les taux d'intérêt sont très élevés à
tel point qu'à l'heure actuelle nous
pensons qu'il n'a aucune trésorerie puis
qui ne payent pas les factures des
quatre ou cinq sociétés de lagence de
presse l'imprimerie une paye aucun
aucune facture une ligne très très
grosses sommes alors si jamais nous
arrivions à la rupture puisque nous la
voulons pas se voulant respectueux notre
signature il condamnait de très très
lourds dommages intérêts ou
présentent-ils l'argent pour sa part
jean charles ligne elle conteste
précisément le montant de ces factures
une chose est certaine la paix le
progrès 150 millions de francs plus que
robert hersant on a déversé pour le
figaro l'argent a été emprunté aux
banques
il va falloir bien sûr remboursés si la
séparation entre les deux journaux
devient effectif l'art doit appuyer pour
le progrès pourrait s'élever à quelques
35 millions de francs le 24 octobre
personnel du groupe dauphiné libéré de
progrès s'est mis en grève
un but garantir les 3000 emplois mais
déjà les deux directeurs ont assuré
qu'il n'y aurait pas de licenciement
avec la séparation des deux journaux ces
deux sons conception du journalisme qui
désormais s'affrontent le progrès avec
440 mille lecteurs et le dauphiné libéré
trois cent trente mille sont des forces
considérables dans la région
les forces politiques et des forces
économiques jean-charles ligne aile le
nouveau venu a bien des atouts dans sa
main mais il n'a pas encore gagné la
partie je pense que de toute façon le
progrès a déjà changé qu'il va changer
que les lecteurs de toute façon vont
avoir à gagner de la concurrence qui va
se réouvrir la pluralité de
l'information pour les journalistes et
pour les lecteurs est toujours quelque
chose de très important
jean-charles ligne aile aujourd'hui on
ne donne pas un chèque en blanc mais il
nous donne beaucoup d'espoir et puis
derrière tout cela il ya un petit peu
une lutte d'influencé politique qui
cache son nom d'ailleurs un partage du
territoire de la région rhône alpes
une dernière minute que j'apprends à
l'instant
sylvie jeanjacquot lalami de mesrine
vient d'être inculpé de recel de
malfaiteurs et placé sous mandat de
dépôt et puis une petite larme à la fin
de ce journal
line renaud quitte la scène certains
d'entre vous pensaient que c'était déjà
fait il n'en était rien l'une des
vedettes les plus populaires de la
chanson française continue à descendre
depuis vingt ans les fameux escaliers du
casino de paris ce soir
elle valait descendre pour la dernière
fois tout au moins c'est ce qu'elle dit
c'est jamais la meute est aussi bien
aujourd'hui sur les régions
méditerranéennes et dans les régions du
sud ouest du pays le soleil est au
rendez vous partout ailleurs le ciel
était très nuageux avec de nombreuses
plus demain sur la moitié nord du pays
le temps sera nuageux avec pluies et
vents d'ouest assez fort sur la moitié
sud
d'assez belles éclaircies apparaîtront
en alternance avec ce que l'on appelle
les passages nuageux
voilà avant de vous quitter je vous fixe
les prochains rendez vous que vous avez
avec l'information tout d'abord tout de
suite
immédiatement après une petite page de
publicité les dossiers de l'écran qui
seront consacrés à une affaire encore
tout à fait récente l'assassinât du juge
renaud avec comme invités le garde des
sceaux
et puis après les dossiers de l'écran
vers 23h30
hervé claude enfin demain à 12 heures 45
ce sera patrick lecocq pour antenne 2010
bonsoir à tous à demain